can we talk about the real because i i
thought it was a great show and you and
the ladies had this bond you were there
from the beginning so how hard is it to
let that go now
it's hard because
the show is the first of its kind when
you have a show that is by minority
voices for minority voices yes i gotta
say i didn't have a show like that when
i started and even today i'm like you
know where can i go that has such a
great culmination of different aspects
and women's perspectives that come from
different lives and cultures
especially as an asian woman i don't see
that representation enough
networks
if you look at your cast if it look if
you look at your writers if you look at
the your directors the people in your
team if it doesn't reflect the melting
pot that is out there make some changes
it has to look like what we see out here
in our audience absolutely
getting off the show is it was hard
because i still think we need a show
like that you know so if we open doors
for other shows like that to be in
production i'm excited about that i want
to see that happen
when people ask me like what's it feel
like being you know one of the only
vietnamese americans in tv it feels
lonely
it doesn't feel great you know so i want
to open that up more for the aapi
community
and at the same time
i'm proud of the reel for what we did we
were iconic are you keeping in touch
with the ladies absolutely yeah the
girls um we keep in touch we have that
we have our text thread i think that's
the greatest and from here on like the
girls they're gonna soar i mean
g-money garcelle adrian lonnie like
you're not it's not the end of seeing
them
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about jobs because you always
have jobs that's the thing like genie
works um holy moly has begun tell me
about the new season
okay i think for every adult out there
you need to have something that reminds
you you ain't got it all like you i you
you you still you could be you could be
laughed at and holy moly is that
humbling moment in everybody's life
where
you're like oh my gosh what
wtf like can i really be going through
this holy moly is an intense
high octane
crazier bigger than life golf course
that has nothing to do with golf that's
a crazy thing like you got a hole in
this obstacle through corn that you've
got to weed through and jump through to
actually make it to but it really has
nothing to do with gulf it has to do
with could you have survived that
altitude could you have made it through
the cornhole could you have made it
through the distractions that are coming
at you gophers that are trying to like
pull you away so these people across
america have found such a favorite show
i can't believe how we have been the
most loved show for the summer all
because americans need an excuse to go
and play
[Music]